[Music]
hello YouTube just Louis in my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the
sixth episode of my loewenthal sessile
interprete from the black perspective in
this episode we are going to look at the
moon eight Queen to c7 by white which
arises after the following order Evo c5
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 d4c captures
d4 Knight captures default ePHI night to
be far and after a 6 we invite this
night on the juicy d6 square with a
check and then we exchanged with the
bishop and challenge the white queen
with Queen to f6 and now white continue
with Queen to c7 keeping his Queen right
into black corpse
personally I think Queen to c7 is not a
dangerous move the simple reason is now
you can see the c2 point is unguarded
and in many variation we are going to
target that pawn and get our three-piece
development okay here our first
Universal move Knight G to e7 and idea
is very simple we want to play d4 if it
is allowed by the white camp well 99% of
the game continued Knight to c3 which
stopped the move defy however you should
also note that in some games White has
played the move c4 but as the C 2 square
is more weak after night to d4 white is
having a huge problem in all the games
so let's continue with the obvious move
Knight to c3 controlling the D Phi
Square and as I mentioned earlier here
comes the first important memory marker
guys remember against Queen to c7 you
are going to play this Tim mattock
attacking move Knight to be full and by
doing so black has two threats
number one there is a folk on c2 looming
and the second obvious threat is yup we
want to play defy and fear our all piece
play then obviously that has only one
decent move in this position namely
Bishop to d3 however few games in the
database continue with Knight to e4
which is not a right continuation and
the simple refutation goes as follows
defy attacking the knight Knight to b6
attacking the black rook so white is
going for the tactical battle which I
don't think so is right option as black
goes for this simple sequence night cap
to see to check if Queen takes C 2 then
Queen captures b6 and black is a clear
pawn up so that's not the choice white
has to play k2d Vern
and after that yep we are going to
capture the rook in the corner which
allows also white to grab the rook in
the corner but now it's black turn and
black has this wonderful move in the
picture namely Queen captures f2 and
after the whole transaction it turns out
that not only black come up with a clear
point advantage but there are some
devastating threats or looming which is
not healthy for the white can you can
check out this position in any
professional engine and it will tell you
a good amount of advantage to the black
cap
okay Bishop to d3 what else and again
the one important thing I like to
highlight in this version is you will
never take on d3 unless and until why it
force you to do it our night is very
superiorly placed and is always looking
to the sea to square so white is never
going to move this bishop in near future
after Bishop to d3 we are going to
continue with of a thematic break defy
and if you can achieve this break in any
of the white variation black is
instantly better in almost all the lines
now as for the arrows I have shown the
most popular choice by white and amongst
them Castle is the main line however
let's start with other moves first
the first move I want to consider is he
captures defy which is a pretty bad
choice by the white cam the simple
reason is after the few captioners let's
say night captors defy night captures d
fired night captors defy attacking the
Queen Queen has the only logical square
namely Quinto c5 which stops black
castling but not to worry after this
move black gerd a very free piece play
so for example a sample line can goes
like this Bishop to e6 planning to play
rook to CH and after castle on the Kings
side black indeed continue with group 2
CH and if white still want to stop the
castle then he has to play Queen to b3
but after blacks next reply Queen to e7
I think black is already in the driver
seat the simple reason is after Queen
captures a7 and King captures ISA one
look at the number of pcs black has
developed and he has a very simple plan
to execute namely H who goes to the D
file and if allow the knight will also
jump to the juicy before square all in
all I think this position is quite
pleasant for the black and with some
careful analysis you have all the very
chances in the tournament factories for
your reference I have attached a model
game in the PG so don't forget to watch
it
the second move I want to consider is
Bishop to d2 and here comes the second
important memory marker guys apart from
he captures defy if you openly respond
with any of the moves then we are going
to continue with d4 not only grab the
space on the Queen side but meanwhile we
are also attacking the white knight and
white has very limited options there are
two genuine tries by white and let's see
each bite on the first move I want to
consider is Knight to e2 and as now
white unleash the attack on the b4 night
we have to capture on d3 and after pawn
captures d3 we are going to continue
with Knight to c6 giving protection to
the e5 square so a queen can
counter-attack the White Queen okay
White Castle on the Kings side we are
going to castle on the Kings side and
now in almost all the games white
continue with this team attic break f4
challenging the black center well if you
are playing against a higher seed and if
you want a safe game then my
recommendation is you should continue
with Queen to d8 which forced the Queen
exchange and resulting position is quite
equal ish for the black cam and you can
check out my analysis in the PG n
however we are looking at some
aggressive and attacking options in this
line and that's why my own
recommendation in this position is you
should continue with this tactical move
Bishop to g4
as the white knight get attacked the
most popular choice is Knight to g3 but
here comes my own invention guys there
is a nice little trap exist in this line
which start with rook to see it
attacking the Queen Queen has to go to
the b6 square because if white continue
with Queen captures b7 then he rightly
fall into her trap as after the move
rook C to b8 that Queen is more or less
trap and she has only one square to go
Queen to c7 afterwards rook to e7 trap
the sweetie forever
you might ask hang on but what about
avoid counter-attack your queen well
then the case is very simple we are
going to first take the rook and after
rook takes and the move rook capture see
seven black emerged with a whole rook up
so that's the nasty line if you open and
become greedy the more general responses
Queen to b6 and against these I am also
going to show you one of the very tricky
model starting with he captures f4 so at
first sight it looks like after rook to
f4 attacking two sports so black
responds his force black has to play
Queen to b6 and if you carefully look at
this position after the moves three
black light square bishop has a complete
collar as he doesn't have any space to
run but believe it or not this is
exactly black Vaughan's as we have
cooked up this nice little surprise
starting with Knight to be far so if I
take the Queen then will take back with
the bishop and our Bishop is no longer
in the trouble if Queen captures d4 then
rook to d8 is a very strong reply so
considering all these options white
shouldn't go for the tactical ideas and
he can calmly retreat the Queen back to
a5 and asking black hey now what isn't
that Bishop is a goner well yes indeed
that's true except we are going to
sacrifice in a style with Bishop
captures h3 pawn captured s3 and now
Queen captures a ch3 if Queen captures
ePHI then Queen captures g3 is a very
strong reply so accordingly White has
the only move in this position namely
Knight to a5 which in fact creating two
deadly threats okay for the time being
we have to defend this so rook to e8 is
obvious choice and now you can see the
obvious threat Knight to f3 and White is
in a huge trouble
in fact there is a game in the database
continue with rook to f2 but after
black's obvious response Knight to f3
white is obliged to capture this night
and when black recapture you can see the
problem in the white camp now yes indeed
he has two pcs for a roof and a to pawn
but I think these three connected passed
pawns are too much strong in endgame and
indeed later on black managed to win the
game so this is one of the great
attacking line which you can use in the
tournament practice with a great
surprise value the second new I want to
consider is Knight to e4 and against
this here comes the third important
memory mark on whenever you open plays
Knight to e4 in this line the more you
have to remember is Queen to c6
attacking to sports so white responses
force white has to exchange the Queen
and then we are going to recapture it
with our Knight protecting of a brother
okay
Knight to b6 attacking to spot no
problem we are going to continue it rook
to b8 and now it doesn't matter whether
white continue with castle or f4 let's
say most frequent choice here is castle
on the King side black castle on the
King side and now once again this
traumatic break f4 so at first sight
this position looks so good for the wide
as he is not undermining of a Sentinel
but he also has a bishop pair and our
pieces looks bit cramped well that's the
current situation but it can be changed
drastically after few moves with Knight
captures d3 pawn captures d3 and now the
star mo in this position fi and with
this move black conforms his slight
advantage in this position
in fact in the database there are only
two games played from this position and
in both the games white continue with
the critical response half captures ePHI
so idea is very simple black cannot
recapture as after Bishop Clare for
black has a lost position but never mind
black is not in a hurry and he can
calmly continue with Bishop to e6 if
Knight to d5 and Bishop captures d fire
and I have attached a sample analysis in
the PGN so again the most critical
response is Bishop to a fool protecting
the e5 pawn
so so far white is having all the fun
and now it's black stone so the first
obvious move which we are going to play
is f captures efore which gives white
this horrible pawn and now very sneaky
idea rook to f7 and believe it or not
this mu create a deadly threat of
capturing ready to born so for example a
casual white player can continue with h3
and after that he can by force get the a
to pawn with the following sequence rook
to f8 attacking the bishop and once the
bishop move we can exchange the rook on
the f1 Square and then grab this loose
pawn on a2 which gives a comfortable
winning advantage to the black camp
so obviously White has to stop it and it
doesn't matter whether he continued with
a 3 or B 3 let's say one of the game
continued with b3 and black continue
with his obvious plan rook to a faint
after Bishop to g3 all the rooks
disappear from the board and the net
result is after the Moon Knight to be
full we are again getting that loose a
to pawn
if a three then night to see two is a
very strong reply but some of you may
ask okay what can lose on a two but on
the counter part what can grab the loose
default bones right well yes that's true
but see yourself as after king to e to
nightcap - Z - King to D 3 black again
has this nice moon in the picture namely
nitrous even check the point is after
King captures d4 and the Moon Knight
captures b3 suddenly black get too
distant parcel and with some careful and
accurate play you can definitely convert
this position into the winning advantage
your engine might say this position is
equal but as for the human perspective
and in the tuner and pressure this
position can only favor the black camp I
have attached rest of the game in the
pgl we're slowly black converted his
full point
so finally we are reaching the main line
with castle on the Kings side and you
know the plan right yup we are going to
get the space on the Queen side with Dee
for attacking the knight and White
Knight has again two squares to go
amongst them the easiest one is Knight
to e4 which we are going to meet with
our third important memory mocker Queen
to c6 exchanging the Queen and then
after Knight to b6 rook to b8 White has
two choices if your opponent continued
here with the MU f4 which in fact the
only independent more in this position
then my solution is you should respond
with f6 and the resulting position is
quite okay for the black and you can
check out a model game in the PGN which
can highlight the plan of campaign from
the black side however the most popular
choice in this position is to play
Bishop to d2 which in fact directly
transpose to over last variation which
goes as follows Knight captures d3 pawn
captures d3 castle on the Kings side and
after the wherefore do you remember yup
it's fi and we reach to the exact same
position
you
you
so now comes the last option night we do
and against this more or less we have
the same plan of campaign castle on the
kingside
f4 and if you recall in bishop to d2
variation we play this aggressive move
Bishop to g4 which is in fact we are
going to also play in this variation at
the moment black has a simple threat
namely Knight captures d3 and then
Bishop captures e to something which
White has to addressed immediately
again the moon night to g3 is not Google
as after the move rook to c8 black
attacking to soft spot
and unfortunately white cannot defend
both of them
Queen captures b7 is very risky for the
white cam so the accurate response is
Queen captures ePHI but after that we
can go for this simple sequence Queen
captures if I have kept to Z Phi night
to c2 attacking the rook and after
Bishop capture C to look after c2 with
the naked eye you can easily see that
not only black has tremendous piece
activity but why it has this horrible
pawn structure at the center of the wall
which gives black ample opportunity to
play for the devastating attack
so considering night 2 G 3 is not
working more or less what has the only
good response in this position namely
1/2 captures ePHI and against this my
recommendation is you go for this very
tactical line starting with Quinn to c6
White has two options if you continue
with Quinn catches a 7 then after Knight
captures d3 the e2 Knight is hanging and
the logical response Knight captures d4
completely fails due to the simple move
Queen captures e4
you
so with undeveloped Pease going for the
tactics is not a good idea by the white
can so the natural response is Quinn
capture c6 afterwards we are going to
continue with capturing with a night
again our threat remain as it is and
accordingly white has to move the knight
so Knight to f4 is a logical response
but after that we can get our pawn back
with Knight captures ePHI now to
illustrate the danger in this position I
like to show you one of the higher end
game where white continue with Bishop to
d2 attacking the knight and black
continue with the obvious sequence
Knight captures d3 pawn captures d3 and
rook to c8 grabbing the open sea father
well white doesn't like it so he
challenged it but there comes a very
nice move rook captures even rook
captures even and now comes the star mu
g5 well white goes for the tactics with
Knight to d5 but this can easily diffuse
by the simple move in the world epics
and now how you going to save the d3
form in fact you can't and correctly
white continue with the aggressor
responds rook to c7 counter attacking
the p7 bomb
well again black response is very nice
rook to f7 challenging the rook and
after the move Knight to e7 he calmly
continue with King to g7 so now indeed
d3 pony's hanging so I thought okay no
issues I am going to get the b7 pawn and
after the move Knight captures d3
suddenly he realized that oops my knight
is pinned and king is coming on FA with
trapping down that nine so he continued
with Bishop to e5 which has an idea to
defend with Bishop to d8 but what he
misters after King to f8 Bishop to d8
and the MU King - eh white indeed lose
the piece and the key
you
that's it guys with this detailed
analysis now you're confident enough to
meet the mu8
Queen to c7 remember this very simple
idea by black cam that after Knight to
e7 Knight to c3 we have this little moon
knight to b4 which allow black to free
up his game with the moon defy and in
almost all the lines black get a
perfectly reasonable game well thank you
for watching this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment and I'll meet
you in my next episode very soon bye and
take care